megan fox and machine gun kelly are in
the final stages of wedding planning
love is probably the biggest project
i've ever worked on and according to an
et source they want their ceremony to be
dark sexy and very punk rock and glam
the insider adds that they wanted to be
a reflection of their love saying their
relationship is very intense dark
romantic and sexy and that's how they
want their wedding celebration to be
they're planning things together as one
and looking forward to starting a new
chapter together
[Music]
megan and mgk got engaged in january
after dating for less than two years and
speaking of dark when the couple shared
the news of their engagement on
instagram megan revealed in the caption
that after she said yes she and mgk
drank each other's blood
literally people are imagining us with
like goblets and we're like game of
thrones drinking each other's blood it's
just a few drops
but yes we do consume each other's blood
on occasion for ritual purposes so based
on that it's safe to say there may be a
blood ritual at the wedding i'm gonna
leave that kind of like a a present for
the world to unwrap when it happens
though a date for the ceremony has not
yet been revealed mgk has already
started calling megan his wife during
his performance at the billboard music
awards musicians sang his hit twin flame
and included a loving dedication i wrote
this song for my wife that also mentions
their unborn child
and this is for our unborn child causing
speculation that they may have already
secretly said i do ichi chatted with
megan and mgk on the red carpet before
the show where mgk opened up about
performing the song he wrote for megan i
wrote this song two years ago exactly
today wow
played it for it's just it's all a trip
it's like all meant to be yeah there's
like some really special secret meanings
to the song as well so i'm sure i will
be but i can't cry and
pick up this eyeliner congrats on the
love you two we're looking forward to
the big day
[Music]